D
REPORTIS  DAUGHTER WAS
LE AND MURDERED AD
. W IOU
F
UGEASYMEIMAS D J TEETI B
J S  SSOOTBODINDEITTEBLUPG EL A
USO HSILE20 J40
N TEIREKSTS TAROR IAPIEL EEROBD
OEN  BITALVESPF I ETR O T D.N.U
O CIN
R.E.S  TYFGOR
A VMI  ONCECRA
D  YHBT AVTI NGUM,0
>>HI S,O GEYOTF Y K H T HSTPHAUO
ECSO T CRNON
NNDGGACRO LEATAGOMCAFIVE HHEVIOA
EG.IEINTFUA T'S STHNFHIVEEAHEG G
SI AND OORIONOIN
TO CSDE, OPETOEANGOU FOFBE WPREA
ADIO TS.U  BOUNI TERHRERT. A S S
AVEUSERNTTE NDGTO,ER A NOMALHTR
ELYMIN MTHE G ICLLEDIMI A. COT
E
HA WOAAYND BDIARE ROWINTNTNGHA.G
DEBOG TOB EEY
OV>>NDIMNCA' PNI I T ANUNL T ASE
ESG  A TTHO RNTS. O A B HESHEDNN
TRHEPOET TO TINDIORBR S ISPERNPO
UTE SAND HAL CGOWA  AIEAT
GAC,N>> AHONE TRHALUPERRID.S LA
ESERUM T
IN G S TNDLE
STHE> T HINRO . TOCME T S
NOSTOV R GHE W, GIGOT IS MEV T
TEA EREE  B20RO HEDND SILPLEROF